[Music]
in american politics there's an idea
that the president basically determines
the price of gas
that whatever you're paying at the pump
it's always their fault
drivers are paying a heavy price for the
bush administration's failure to enact a
comprehensive energy strategy the gas
pump is 100 on biden's desk it's 100 his
fault
but that's not very accurate at the very
simplest level the price of oil is
pretty much a reflection of supply and
demand
the more oil there is on the market the
less that oil is going to be worth
but think about who controls the energy
market groups like the organization of
petroleum exporting countries or opec
decide how much oil is going to be
pumped in order to basically set global
prices
and energy companies decide with
influence from their shareholders how
much oil they're going to be producing
but unlike the consumers who of course
want low prices the suppliers have an
incentive to keep prices high
even in times of crisis
gas prices are inching up the price of
crude oil has jumped and that could
cause gas prices to rise even more
they're now spiking because of worries
about global oil supplies the price of
oil and gas going up has an inflationary
impact unlike anything else
so oil companies could expand domestic
production to face the crisis
but they've been very hesitant to do
that
instead of ramping up production
elsewhere in the world investors and
owners of these oil companies are
engaging in capital discipline
according to the ceos of these companies
and telling them that we don't want you
to go out and drill more oil because we
don't think that that's going to be
profitable for us in the long term
[Music]
for the last 10 years or so the
financial community has given lots of
money to these oil companies to engage
in exploration especially especially in
fracking and those investments turned
out actually not to be profitable and
they basically just don't want to do
that again
this is matt brunig of the people's
policy project he's a policy analyst
with a particular focus on economics and
he's pointing out something that
happened a few years ago
in the 2010s investors lost money
because oil supply was too high and
prices too low
due to massive expansion of drilling
american shale alone lost 300 billion
dollars
while motorists enjoyed what amounted to
a huge gas subsidy
so those investors learned they now
encourage oil companies not to produce
in order to inflate profits
in the words of one financial analyst
quote it's not the government that is
banning them from drilling more it's
pressure from their shareholders
that's why a survey of oil and gas
executives found that the overwhelming
reason for low production was not
government action but quote investor
pressure to maintain capital discipline
so that's the truth about why energy
prices are so high
it's a system of upwards redistribution
and the only way to stop it is to stop
being so dependent on oil and gas
just look at a country like france
in france nuclear power is the leading
source of energy housing is much denser
and public transportation is decent so
the french have been relatively
cushioned from the effects of oil price
shocks simply because they are not so
dependent on oil
of course switching your society's built
environment away from oil requires a lot
of time
so you need to think seriously about how
to put the oil industry into a sort of
managed decline
while also controlling prices for
ordinary car driving consumers who often
have no other choice but to drive
we can't have it go on forever because
obviously that would wreck the climate
we also can't end it immediately because
we don't have enough clean energy to
replace it so
the oil industry needs to be put on a
managed decline but private investors
are not in the business of temporarily
propping up industries they think are
dying in the face of huge efforts to
phase out fossil fuel extraction
the commitment to largely end the use of
fossil fuels we are on course for
devastating changes to our climate no
more drilling no ability for the oil
industry to continue to drill period
so if private actors are unable to
manage this transition public ownership
might be necessary by bringing the
public ownership you can kind of manage
both ends of it you can make sure that
production continues when we need it and
you can make sure that it goes away when
we when we want it to go away
norway is an example that i use
frequently they're state-owned oil
company which is now called ecuanor and
it's been running very well there they
were mostly concerned with capturing the
profits of the industry and making sure
that those profits uh you know serve the
social good
now norway is not perfect
in many ways norway is very hypocritical
about climate in large part because it
is unwilling to actually end its oil
exploration activities
but if you're interested in controlling
gas prices while also having the power
to transition away from fossil fuel
dependence
public actors are still much better
positioned to do that than private ones
it would mean managing oil and gas
extraction not through private actors
motivated by profit but public actors
using that money not for stock buybacks
and executive compensation but
investment in green energy dense housing
and public transportation
a better way is very possible
[Music]
you